every new day inevitably brings in just
another contribution to our knowledge
about the world around us in the past
several decades alone over 4 000
new earth-like exoplanets have been
discovered by mankind
but in order to reach those remote
objects it will take man
inventing engines that would enable
spaceships to travel at ultrasonic
speeds
that is go beyond the limits defined by
physical laws
known today managing this task may well
seem
unlikely however many contemporary
scientists are sure that it is a matter
of time
before these technologies emerge
[Music]
interstellar travel has always been one
of mankind's cherished dreams
over half a century has elapsed since
the launch of the earth's first
artificial satellite and since then
terrestrial spacecraft have covered
truly record distances on escape
trajectories
from the earth the voyages were among
the pioneer spacecraft to set out in
space with a top traveling speed
reaching 62
140 kilometers per hour
juno is the second super fast space
probe worth mentioning here
which approached jupiter at 250 000
kilometers per hour
as for the recently launched parker
solar probe it is able to propel itself
at up to 700 000 kilometers per hour
as a rule the speed of such spacecraft
is generally attained with the use of
gravity boost maneuvers
that is when a spacecraft enters into an
object's orbit
which helps increase its speed this
trick works well within our system
but be it as it may in order to travel
as far as stars
scientists will have to think of other
strategies as there may not be enough
celestial objects on the spaceship's way
through interstellar space
which would help to perform gravity
boost maneuvers
it is quite possible that in the future
terrestrial spacecraft will be able to
reach the ultimate speed for traveling
around the universe
however to date only light is able to
travel that fast
its speed is traditionally considered
the limit and is a constant
at 299 792
458 meters per second
any particle where the mass will never
reach this speed
and any particle without a mass will
always travel at this exact speed
in the vacuum
the concept of an engine which would be
able to exceed the speed of light
has long been considered preposterous in
scientific circles
while considering flying to neighboring
stellar systems was completely
out of the question but as time goes by
and with sufficient global knowledge the
most audacious ideas may prove realistic
thanks to being widely promoted by
science fiction films
the warp drive became the first project
of this scale
the history of its development goes back
to 1994
when mexican scientist miguel coubier
assumed that the concept
of ultrasonic travel could be considered
as einstein's equation
solved in theory the equation defines
the relation between
space time and energy in our universe
in plain language in his theory the
mexican scientist puts forward the idea
of traveling in the manor
when a spacecraft is cocooned in a
bubble of space
the warp drive inside it makes the space
in front of the bubble contract
and the space behind the bubble to
expand with a spacecraft in between
remaining motionless
thus the bubble is able to travel
together with the spaceship at an
unlimited speed which
beats even the speed of light this
travel could be compared with moving on
a surfboard
with a surfer remaining motionless and
the board propelled forward by waves
at the end of last century this idea
could seem pseudo-scientific
but due to a loophole in physical laws
this may be manageable
it isn't the object that is moving but
the space
around it and space is capable of
traveling at greater speeds
than light
by and by still more space-time
properties were discovered by science
and many scientists were attracted by
the concept of the warp drive
in 2007 thanks to the gravity probe b
project the ability of space to get
warped in the vicinity of massive
objects was proved once and for all
in 2015 thanks to the ligo observatory
the first gravity waves were detected in
the form of space-time perturbations
which may be described as ripples in
space
as recently as in august 2008 dozens of
science groups were offered by the
ministry of defense of the united states
to look into prospects of exploring new
aerospace technologies
a report on a warp drive was the most
striking of the presented papers
its authors argued that the creation of
the warp drive would be closely linked
to studying the dark matter
the force that makes the universe expand
with an accelerating velocity
at the time the report prompted a lot of
debates among
dark matter specialists however ten
years later
the idea of a warp jump was brought up
again
in 2019 american engineer joseph agnew
revealed the results of his work
where he was able to break down the
theory of the warp jump propulsion force
into simple comprehensible bits
according to the scientist
the warp deformation can be unleashed by
means of space-time contraction and
expansion
which would be aimed in a specified
direction at a specified time
today the emergence of such technologies
seems unthinkable
but even now scientists are aware of the
fact that high density energy
is able to cause a necessary warp in
time space
in the future science will most likely
have to advance
technologies generating such energy
forms to the ultimate level
which means that only in decades will
these experiments
yield results apart from the futuristic
warp drives however
there is a great number of projects
which are not less exciting
and more down to earth as it were the
iron thruster is one of them
with several organizations currently
working on it
the general principle of its work lies
in ionizing gas
and accelerating it with electrostatic
field
since ions have a mass they can be
accelerated
which will produce the thrust
the ion thruster contains some gas which
is ionized with a gas charge
where gas atoms with a neutral charge
are split into negative electrons
and positive ions after that ions are
accelerated by an electric field
in a sophisticated system of grids this
same system
blocks the movement of electrons on
leaving the nozzle
positive particles are neutralized by
negative electrons
so that the ions do not go back to the
drive and do not
impede its thrust in theory
this method allows accelerating ions up
to 210 kilometers per second
which is considerably higher than the
speed of particles and chemical rocket
jets
used in all contemporary space and
military rockets
their speed reaches just four kilometers
per second
at the moment existing engines of this
kind lack in power
and are applicable only for adjusting
the orbit's trajectory
however if future scientists are able to
create a more powerful version of the
iron thruster
it will allow spaceships to reach the
surface of mars in just
39 days which is approximately seven
times as fast as the current optimal
travel time it takes to get to the red
planet another possible option that may
present itself for traveling to the
neighboring celestial objects
will probably involve nuclear rocket
engines the principle of their work
will lie in a source heating up as a
result of the decay of radioactive
material
this approach was tested at the
beginning of the space age
but so far it has been inapplicable due
to two factors
firstly the use of these technologies
would lead to harmful emissions of large
amounts of radioactive waste into space
secondly the nuclear engine requires
intensive cooling
which would be difficult to achieve in
space only low power nuclear engines are
known to science today
with several countries already working
on the development of more powerful
and safer versions for example in 2017
nasa and bwxt nuclear energy signed a
contract on the development of a
technology of this kind which will
enable terrestrial spacecraft to reach
planets like saturn in a few months time
perhaps even the next generation of
people will live to see the day
when they can freely travel around our
system and cover enormous distances
between
planets within a matter of a few months
however we should remember that all the
projects mentioned currently exist
only in theory and their realization has
equal chances of success
or failure
man will always try to break away from
the limits imposed by the surroundings
sooner or later one of these attempts is
going to be successful
it is quite possible for a breakthrough
to take place even this century
meanwhile what remains for us to do is
to marvel at discoveries in today's
physics
and to hope that the history of mankind
will not
end on this planet
dear friends every new video is a lot of
work
and your support by electronic likes
stimulates us to carry on
that's why don't forget to subscribe if
you like what we're doing
so that you won't miss new videos it's
only thanks to science that we'll be
able to provide ourselves
with a ticket to the future let's keep
in touch
[Music]
so
you